in the next 40 days we're gonna take a
picture of ourselves it's not who
the most weight it's who
the best can we do a vote like a poll on
the internet no it's unfair to Dove but
it feels like that people hate it what
if we do a poll on the street and we
take the heads well that was the other
idea if we could just go objectively
walking up to different people on the
street that don't even know and then
just show the picture whose body is
better Duff also doesn't want to see the
back of his body because it looks like a
surfboard below the chin above your
pubes 360. midsection take your shirt
off who looks better 360. 360. I don't
know
we talked about this no body it's the
whole body dude it's a shirtless picture
a shirtless picture yeah of your front
and back no why are you so afraid of
here because we said 40 days what's
wrong everybody knew what I'm able to do
I love handles that only God can take
care of
but from my front I'll have a six-pack
in 40 days that will be very visible
with a great tan and you will look like
a pumpkin